Hello, and welcome to todays webinar.
My name is Jonathan Trow and I'm a curator
here at SRA and today I'll be demonstrating
how to access our new data format, SRA aligned
reads, and some ofthe features and benefits
that that offers.
As well as how to use Amazons's Athena resource
to search SRA metadata in the cloud and help
narrow your search to runs taht contain data
of interest before you need to download those
data.
Just a quick overview.
We will start out with a little bit of background
of SRA and then will move on to Amazon Web
services Registry of Open Data.
I will explain what SRA aligned read format
is an show how to get started on Athena and
move it to example workflows in Athena.
I will show you how to access the aligned
read format on the command line and then we
will move on to question and answer.
SRA and the cloud.
Why have it?
You can do some of the searching and access
directly at NCBI, why have in the cloud.
SRA archive format is now over 18 petabytes.
Great.
It is a lot of data and there is a lot of
interesting stuff there.
But it is a lot of data that can be really
hard to search, which is not so great.
When there is that much data you need a way
to narrow it down to what you actually care
about.
In this regard, Athena offers a number of
advantages.
It provides new, robust search capabilities
to SRA cloud customers on AWS.
We also have some search features available
on BigQuery for GCP users.
But what Athena allows us to do is to facilitate
fast search using parallel execution of queries
with multiple methods of access.
What I will be showing today is mostly the
browser based query builder which is what
most new users want to start with.
They also have a collection of client libraries
to be used within the workflow or you can
just access it using the command line interface.
You get a fast search in a lot of ways to
access it depending on what your personal
workflow is.
This is a benefit to NCBI because it is a
great foundation for us to continue to update
this and change things and to be able to quickly
respond to user feedback.
I will have an address to write into with
suggested at the end of the presentation and
we need the feedback for people who are using
it to guide future development to figure out
what we want to do next and what is the best
service to our users.
And finally, it can be pretty easy to get
started with SQL.
There is a little bit of a learning curve
if you've never used it but it gives you enough
power with getting down into the data to figure
out what you want.
To that we will go to the first pole.
We just want to gauge for attendees who are
online.
How familiar are you with SQL?
Ranging from I have never heard of it, to
you are a pro and use it all of the time.
This will sort of help us to get a gauge on
that.
It is kind of split.
I will not do an in-depth SQL tutorial today.
We will cover a little bit of basic terminology
for beginners, but we do have a few links
if you want to explore that more and your
new to it.
Let me go ahead and stop sharing the poll.
Now you are back in.
We have a few links to the Amazon documentation
and there is a basic rundown of the implementation
there in Athena.
In addition there are numerous online tutorials,
both free and paid, which can give you a basic
introduction is working with SQL.
The Amazon Registry of open data is a listing
of publicly available data sets and it is
a way to search and find data that has been
made available for general use.
And SRA has had a set of COVID focused data
since July and the new aligned read format
that I will talk about today is also available
there now.
This brings a number of benefits.
It allows you to access a large volume of
Covid-19 read data at full cloud speed and
no cost to you.
In addition, let you analyze the data, in
addition to your own cloud hosted datasets.
You can easily combine these.
If you want to set up a pipeline in the cloud
to combine both datasets it is easy to do
and have your datafiles in a single location
which can be an easier way to deal with some
of the data.
I mentioned the new data format the SRA aligned
reads.
What are those.
The compressed data format.
It is in some way similar to existing SRA
data in that it can be used with the SRA toolkit
to dump new data formats but it has new data
that is not available anywhere else.
Briefly, contigs were created from runs in
SRA that contained coronavirus kmers
that are part of our taxonomy analysis tool.
That uses a kmer approach to identify the
origin of read in a run.
Any run that I had at least 100 hits to Coronaviridae
or child taxa was selected for analysis and
a few other selection criteria were applied
to those like minimum read length and sequencing
platform, and contigs work created from that
set of runs, via guided assembly to the SARS-CoV-2
RefSeq genomic sequence.
If contigs were created and then those were
used mapped back to the contigs and coverage
was calculated.
These SRA aligned read objects contain the
contigs were constructed and they also contain
the raw reads that were used to construct
the contigs.
You can dump that however you want with the
toolkit.
So you have access to the individual reads
or the contigs individually.
If you have the SRA aligned read object you
can use FASTQ-dump from the toolkit to dump
FASTQ just as you would with any normal SRA
run.
but if what you care about is the FASTA contigs
you can get those as well.
One thing I will note is a number of these
bio samples are not present in an Genbank.
These represent a new sequence that is only
available here.
If what you care about are both the contigs
and reads you can see the reads mapped onto
the contigs by using the toolkit to dump in
SAM format.
You can see where those aligned to the individual
contigs.
In addition, the aligned reads are a smaller
size than our standard SRA format.
One reason is that they do not have quality
scores.
This makes them quite a bit smaller to download.
A lot smaller to work with.
Dumps on these objects are much faster.
It is just about getting you into the data
and working with it as quickly as possible.
Here will be the second pole questioning how
familiar you are with Athena.
This is our first release of searching of
metadata in Athena.
I am curious to see how many users are familiar
with it
and have used it before.
The aligned read objects as I'm about to show,
we set up metadata in Athena that lets you
do specific searches on submitted and calculated
metadata to help you find the ones, the specific
contigs or reads that are most interesting
to you.
Looks like the majority of people have not
used it before.
That is great.
We will walk through an example of how to
get it set up if it is your first time.
It is pretty easy to get started.
We have these new aligned read objects with
new data but we also have new metadata you
can query using Athena.
Since people have never used it, what is Athena?
It is a query service for S3 data analysis
it allows you to directly query data stored
in Amazon S3 using SQL syntax.
This means there is no need to manually transform
the data for query.
You do not have to download a file from us
and transform it into some pseudo-database
and try to query it.
Amazon has tools that does is for you automatically
and is really easy to be up and running in
a few minutes.
I will show you an example during set up.
The data that we have uploaded allows you
to use Athena to search taxonomy, BLAST and
annotative results for aligned read contigs.
After the contigs were created for SRA aligned
reads, the taxonomy was assessed via two methods.
The first is that contigs were assessed using
our SARS-CoV-2 detection tool is a similar
kmer approach to the taxonomy tool.
The second is that the contigs were checked
via megablast against a BLAST database.
All of the results are available for querying
in Athena.
It allows you to focus on the runs or reads
that interest you before ever downloading
the data.
You can query these calculated metadata results
in combination with the user submitted metadata
to sample information to get an even more
focused result.
There are two separate buckets of data that
are available for querying.
I will talk about them and I have them in
two columns to try to make it clear two separate
sets.
They can be queried together and you can import
them to the same database, but I will talk
about them separately for conceptual reasons.
The first is this aligned read metadata, calculated
metadata on these contigs.
Here we have individual data on the contigs
like coverage and taxonomy id and contig length,
there is also taxonomy content analysis of
the contigs and you can search for records
based on your taxonomy level of interest for
instance, and there are also BLAST results.
You can search for records based on hits your
accession of interest or the hit length or
the percent identity or the score, for instance.
The S3 bucket address for the metadata is
here.
You do not have to memorize that.
s3://sra-pub-sars-cov2-metadata-us-east-1/
It is also present in the documentation.
It is just there for the record.
In addition to this, we have available total
SRA metadata.
This includes user submitted sample information
for everything in SRA.
Where the geographical location and sample
was collected or the collection technique.
Includes sequencing library information and
the single end or paired end.
As well as taxonomic content analysis for
everything in SRA.
You can search based on kmer hits to your
species of interest or if you want to look
at a metagenome example and get a look at
what is in there by our analysis befor downloading
it yourself.
You can do that also, just get a list of it.
This is the S3 address for that bucket.
s3://sra-pub-metadata-us-east-1/sra/metadata/
Which again is just here for the record.
These can be queried individually but you
can query them together to get a little bit
more of a focused filtered result and I will
show an example of that later.
Since we have some people who are not familiar
with SQL, I will do a very brief crash course
on a couple of key terms to hopefully help
you follow along with the basic query.
First is SELECT this is a command to extrat
data from a table.
You are essentially telling the database what
you want to get back in your answer.
A lot of times you use select star or asterisk.
It is a wildcard to give you everything or
you might say select only the run accessions
to get back.
FROM is a clause to specify which tables to
extract from.
So select the run accessions from the contigs
table, let's say.
And WHERE is the filter for that table.
So Select the run accessions from the contigs
table were coverage is greater than 100 X.
And ORDER BY allows you to order the result
by a specified column.
You might order by coverage descending.
You get the highest coverage first and on
down.
Select the run accessions from the table where
coverage at is at least 100 X.
We are going to go into the actual Athena
demo where I will show the basic set up and
then I will show a few queries as well.
I will begin with the basic query that can
be an easy one to start with if you are new
to SQL and then I will move on to a couple
of more complex queries that connect submitted
sample metadata with ccalculated contigs information.
When you start with Athena, you will see this
page.
Depending on where you have logged in to AWS,
you maybe on various different pages.
You can usually always go to this services
drop down and start typing.
It will auto complete whatever you are looking
for.
Here you can type Athena or if you recently
visited, it will show up over here and you
can star it and put in your favorites.
Any of those you can click on and it will
take you to the start page.
Click the Get started blue button and you
will end up here on the query editor.
And this is where you would actually type
in the queries.
You would not have queries already here like
I do.
In fact, you would not have databases or anything.
What you would need to do is go to connect
data source.
This is how we are going to point Athena at
the data that we want to query.
For a lot of the pages we will leave the settings
on default and I will tell you when that not
is the case.
We will start here and leave it on query data
in Amazon S3 and the AWS Glue data catalog.
And click next.
Here I will leave it on Set up crawler in
AWS glue to retrieve schema information automatically.
The crawler will automatically scan the data
source, the S3 bucket and identify the data
formats and infer the schema.
It will make the database for us out of the
S3 bucket.
If you want to do this manually, you can.
You can import the tables manually and define
the columns and fields.
This is more of a power user move.
We would not recommend this for anyone beginning
or if you do not have a specific reason because
it is more effort and the Glue crawler will
sort of do it automatically which we will
do today.
I will click quickly connect to the AWS glue
button, it opens it up in a new tab and here
we need to give a name for our crawler.
You can call it whatever you want.
I'll call mine Demo2.
We are going to leave this option on Data
stores and click next.
Here you definitely need to make a change.
We need to give it the path to the S3 bucket
we are hoping to query.
So I have that saved over here.
This is just the path to the aligned read
metadata.
Going to paste that here.
Click next.
Here I'm going to say no for add another data
store.
If you wanted to you could go back and add
the total SRA metadata here as well.
If you click yes it will let you put in another
address for instance.
I will leave this as is and click next.
We need to choose a role here.
I'm using a personal account because I think
this is probably what most people would be
using when they were first starting out and
if that is the case, you can sort of just
create a role name.
It can be whatever you want.
If you happen to be logging in through an
institutional account, where they are controlling
all of the roles and policies, you may need
to choose existing role and you would select
here and pick one from the drop-down of available
options.
I'm going to go ahead and create one, ah,
I have used that one before.
Demo10 then.
Certainly I haven't done the many.
Click next.
The frequency, we will have it run on demand.
You do not need to do this every time you
want to query Athena.
This is an initial set up and once we import
it to a database you can come back and query
it whenever you need to.
We will need to run this again if we change
something like adding a new table.
And then we would have communication about
that.
I'm going to click next and finally, we need
to select the database to import this too.
If you have existing runs, you could select
one of those from here.
I'm going to create a new one.
I will call it demo 10.
We can create and click next.
You can look over all of the information that
you put in if you want to go back and change,
you can, it looks okay to me.
I will click finish.
What this does is creates a crawler for you
which is in this list.
If this is your first time you would just
have one.
This is the one that I created.
You can see it has never run before but if
you look at the other crawlies I run in the
past you can see that these usually take one
or two minutes to run.
It is not long.
And the scanning of the data is inexpensive.
It should generally cost less than a dollar.
And to run, if you have selected here you
can click Run crawler, and it will start running.
In the interest of time, I will not wait to
the couple of minutes for this to finish.
I will go ahead and go back to my Athena window.
Where I have already imported databases.
You can see the demo 10.
It doesn't have tables yet but in a minute
or two it will have those tables.
We'll start with an aligned read table that
I have imported previously.
A couple of quick things to show.
You want to see which tables are available
you can click that little down arrow and it
will show you over here on the left and if
you want to go further to look into the contents
of the blastn table, it shows you the different
columns.
The accession, length, bit score, percent
identity, etc.
It can usually be a little bit easier if you
click on these three dots and click Preview
table.
It will show you the first 10 rows.
You can sort of see every thing that is in
it.
You have the run succession.
The name of the contigs.
You have information about the blast hit,
the bit score, the length, the hit percent
identity, etc.
A couple other interface things I'll point
out before I go on to the demo query.
One is that after you run a query it shows
you how long it took and how much data was
scanned.
How much data is scanned is how you are charged
in Athena and they have the pricing on their
website.
It works out to five dollars per terabyte.
All the queries I will show today will cost
pennies and I will cover that more at the
end.
If you wanted to save these results, all the
results are saved to a S3 bucket for you.
But if you want to download the results in
csv format you can click this little button
and it will just download it for you.
If you have a big result to analyze you can
do that and that shows up there.
If you have a query think you want to run
again in the future you will want to check
back in and see if new data is coming into
the query.
Once you have it here in your query window
you can click save as.
Give it a name and description.
When you click save it will show up here under
your saved queries.
You can see that I have some here.
If I click on one of these it will bring it
up in my query window here.
If this is your very first time using Athena,
one more thing you want to do is go to this
workgroup tab you will need to have a workgroup
with a S3 bucket associated with it, which
is where your results will be stored.
If you already have a workgroup with a S3
bucket associate you can select it here and
click the switch workgroup button and it will
be active.
If not you can create click create workgroup
give it a name and enter the address of your
S3 bucket and click create down here and it
will show up in this list and you can switch
to it.
I will show and example of a query now.
This is the first query.
I will go ahead and run this.
This is a pretty basic one.
We are just querying the contigs table and
this just has a list of all of the contigs
that are constructed with the SRA aligned
read object.
I'm selecting everything from the contigs
table where the tax I.D. for SARS-CoV-2 and
the coverage is greater than 100 X in length
is greater than 20,000.
You can see my result down here.
This just gives you a list of all the contigs
that might be of interest to you.
If you are a beginner to SQL, this might be
a simple one that you can use.
You can toy with some of these options instead
of coverage, maybe you would want to look
at hits just to get a sense of how you can
change these queries to get the results you're
actually interested in.
You can see that it shows the data scanned.
Only 42 megabytes in this case.
This cost less than one penny, actually.
You can do some interesting stuff.
And I think if you combine submitted metadata
with our calculated metadata, you get more
interesting results.
This is an example of that.
Here I am querying both the total SRA submitted
metadata and the BLAST results for aligned
reads.
I'm starting with a subquery where I am selecting
all of the run accessions from the BLAST results
where they got a BLAST results where it had
a taxid for sars-cov-2.
For all those accessions, I'm going to the
submitted metadata for the runs.
I'm getting the name of the country where
this sample was collected and taking a count
of the country each time a country comes up
and ordering by that count.
What we see where for all of these contigs,
where were those samples actually collected.
We have 1700 from the USA.
1600 from Australia and on down.
If, for instance, you're interested in a specific
region, like South Africa, you could drill
down into that more carefully, and look at
the actual data underlying that.
Here is one more example.
If, for instance, you are interested in the
South African data, I am here querying the
total SRA metadata table and looking for samples
that were collected in South Africa.
I am using all of the runs that return and
I am looking for the corresponding hits in
the aligned reads BLAST table.
Any of the runs collected in South Africa,
which one had blasted SARS-CoV-2.
I'm looking at those and the maximum bit score.
You get the maximum bit score over here and
you have the contigs listed over here.
You can see that there are a number of good
hits from this run in particular.
If you wanted to go and search, and get the
data for this run, you can do that pretty
easily.
I am here, bringing up a command line tool.
I'm just logged into a little ec2 instance
here.
This is really easy to get started with.
If you have no experience with this, on our
cloud YouTube channel, we have a little video
to shows you how to start a ec2 instance and
get the toolkit installed.
It is a little six minute video.
It is very easy.
This is a free tier instance it doesn't cost
a lot to get started on this.
Once you have a run of interest that you want
to look at the aligned reads for in the contigs,
you plug the run accession into this S3 address.
No need to memorize.
It is in the documentation and I will have
a link at the end.
Here I am using the Amazon command line interface
to copy this to my Instance.
When I do that, you can see it copies very
quickly and I now have this SRA aligned reads
files here.
One you have that you can interact with it
using the toolkit, as you would a normal run.
If you wanted to dump the FASTQ you can do
that.
I will just just dump the first 5 reads to
standard out it will be more easily seen.
You can dump FASTQ if you want, get the raw
reads out and do your own alignment or analysis.
As you can see, has placeholder quality scores
because the qualities have been removed from
these read align objects.
If what you really care about are the fasta
contigs which may represent a new sequence,
they are not samples that are in Genbank.
You can get just that out.
So use the dump-ref-fasta tool to dump the
contigs from the object.
I will dump this to a file here.
The dump is quite fast and if you look at
the top of the file, you can see that we have
the contig name along with the sequence and
they are all in here.
If we just grep for all the contig names,
we have the entire set of contigs from just
this run in one single file.
If what you prefer is to look at the aligned
read information you can use sam-dump to dump
that out, standard out by default.
You can see on the header all the assembly
references are contigs.
Here you have the reads aligned to those contigs.
If you want to visualize where they align
you can do that as well.
If you want the reads in fasta you can do
that as well.
You can interact with these in the toolkit
just like you would any other object in SRA.
But you get these extra contigs not represented
anywhere else.
They are designed to be small and fast to
work with.
Give you access to the underlying reads and
the assembled contigs in whatever format makes
most sense for your pipeline.
And the Athena add-on allows you to narrow
your search to specific data of interest before
you need need to download or dump the data.
So you don't need to download dump align the
data yourself to see if there's interest there.
That's already been done.
You can use the BLAST results or the contig
results to confirm that the data are of interest
to you immediately, that it have the taxonomy
hits that you are interested in and then just
pull the runs that you know have useful information
and start analyzing from there.
The queries are also included in the presentation.
That's available for download.
Quick note on cost.
Predicted cost in Athena.
The original first query which was contigs
by length cost less than a penny.
The other two, the geographic location by
count and the top BLAST hits cost about ten
cents.
These are the cost based on current pricing,
that could change at any point in the future.
As you can see it's easy and cheap to get
started.
If this is something you are interested in
I would encourage you to do that.
Which leads me to feedback is welcome.
We rely on our users to help us improve these
resources.
Please check out SRA in the cloud and Athena.
And let us know what you think.
If there problems, or things we can make better
let us know and let us know what other future
features you would like.
We will continue development of this we want
to know what's most useful to the scientific
community.
You can use this address,
suggest@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
Finally a couple of quick URLs.
The first is a link to our cloud documentation.
https://tinyurl.com/SRAcloudDoc
It has the S3 addresses for all the Athena
data, the S3 data in Athena I showed you today.
Also further documentation on Athena that
has definitions on all the tables and fields
and so if there is a table or field that you're
not sure what it is is defined there take
a look at that.
There's also information on taxonomic analysis
tool if you want to look at that.
I have a link to Amazon's Athena documentation
on saving query results.
https://docs.aws.amazon.com/athena/latest/ug/querying.html#saving-query-results
it's a little more complete than what I showed
today.
Finally, here's are getting started playlist
for SRA on the cloud on YouTube.
https://tinyurl.com/SRAonthecould
That has the video I mentioned about how to
set up an ec2 instance and get started with
the tool kit really quickly and other things
that might be useful.
Finally, we've got the NCBI general help email
address
info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
and SRA help email address:
sra@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
so if you're trying to work on this and having
trouble with the tables you can write SRA
and we'll be happy to give you assistance
with that.
Thank you very much for your attention and
I would be happy to take any questions you
may have.
[Peter Cooper] Thank you Jonathan.
There are questions.
I'm not completely clear what this person
is asking.
Basically want to know is the GISAID accessions
are they mapped over in the SRA data in the
cloud?
[Jonathan Trow] I am not sure about that.
Here in Athena you mean?
[Peter Cooper] The person asked the question
if they could clarify exactly what you want
to know.
Part of the question is whether we have all
the data at all I think.
The GISAID is the flu resource collecting
the SARS-CoV-2 data.
[Jonathan Trow] It's not available in the
tables currently.
It may be available at NCBI, I'm not 100%
sure about that.
We can certainly get an answer for that.
[Peter Cooper] Another question.
For nanopore sequence reads, is the raw instrument
out put data available?
[Jonathan Trow] Yes.
Yes the raw output data is available for nanpore
sequencing reads.
That is distinct from the SRA aligned reads
I was showing you.
We do provide the raw.
Assuming it was submitted sometimes they will
submit nanopore as fastq so in those cases
we don't have it.
If the raw data is submitted we should have
it and it should be available from the cloud.
[Peter Cooper] Thank you.
This question is good because it falls on
something you just said about the YouTube
channel.
There asked me was that there in equivalent
webinar for using BigQuery and GCP and the
answer is yes, and that webinar is available
on the YouTube channel.
That doesn't talk about the read align objects
we're talking about today.
[Jonathan Trow] That's right, that covers
total SRA metadata.
That is all that was available then.
It does not cover read align objects.
Or the metadata like the blast results and
the contig information.
[Peter Cooper] Are they also available on
GCP?
[Jonathan Trow] They are.
[Peter Cooper] This is a question I am often
confused about, it's about egress charges.
The question is for the SRA public datasets
on AWS or GCP, are there data egress charges
you want to download your query results for
analysis.
[Jonathan Trow] For the data in the open data
registry, that's COVID related stuff I just
talked about which includes the new aligned
reads there is no egress charge for that.
That is provided free of charge.
However, for most if not all SRA data that's
on the cloud, there is an egress charge.
If you want some other run that's in the cloud
and you want to download it to storage, that
would have an egress charge.
[Peter Cooper] Thank you, Jonathan.
Another question is are you aware of any client
software that offers a higher level of abstraction.
In other words I think they're looking for
something that we will look at either AWS
or Athena or GCP in a platform independent
manner, does that make sense?
[Jonathan Trow] You mean to query this data
you get some other --
[Peter Cooper] So it wouldn't be dependent
on Athena and the BigQuery stuff is there
something that works across the platforms,
I think that is the question.
[Jonathan Trow] For querying, probably, I'm
not aware of one offhand.
The data we stored at S3 is in parquet format.
It's designed to be efficiently queried by
Athena.
It's also offered in json if that's what you
want.
I'm sure there's a way you can query that
independently if you wanted to, but it's not
particularly designed for that.
The stuff in Athena has been tweaked to be
efficient and quickly searched in Athena.
[Peter Cooper] This question.
I'm not sure I understand if we can see if
this is relevant to the webinar or not.
The question is, it's not related to Athena,
I just wanted to know know which database
the PA NV scores can be found.
I don't know what those are, do you?
[Jonathan Trow] I don't think I know what
that is.
[Peter Cooper] That's all the questions we
have directly you related to the webinar today.
I'm going to go ahead and end the webinar
for everyone and thank you for coming.